[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
connaissez-vous la french tech la french
tech
c'est un label qui regroupe l'ensemble
des jeunes entreprises innovantes
françaises dirigées par des
entrepreneurs audacieux et financé par
des ex entrepreneur devenus à leur tour
conseiller et investisseurs je fais
partie de la première génération de ces
entrepreneurs de l'internet suivi
maintenant par deux autres générations
je me concentre aujourd'hui à la
transformation numérique de la finance
et plus particulièrement du paiement je
dirige l'association professionnelle des
acteurs innovants du paiement en france
pilier de ce qu'on appelle les fintec
fintec ce sont ces entreprises qui
regroupe finances et nouvelles
technologies
le fil conducteur de mon audace
c'est la recherche de la rupture de la
disruption et disruption toute pensée
al'inverse de la pensée commune et c'est
en général la meilleure façon pour
innover être disruptif c'est sortir du
cadre se libérer des contraintes c'est
rêver alors ce soir je vous propose
pendant quelques instants de rêver avec
moi imaginez un monde sans mener sans
argent pas de chéquier pas de billets
pas de carte bancaire ce monde a existé
pendant dix millions d'années pourrait
changer les hommes faisait du troc
ils échangeaient pomme contre eux 20 20
contre charbon avec l'avènement de l'ère
agricole l'homme a spécialisé sa
production il s'est sédentarisé il est
devenu de plus en plus dépendant de ses
échanges avec les autres alors
rapidement le troc est devenu une
contrainte il a fallu inventer autre
chose l'homme fit alors une invention
extraordinaire probablement la plus
grande invention de l'humanité une
révolution purement mental il inventa la
monnaie
c'était il ya seulement cinq mille ans
et monnaie tout ce que les gens tout ce
que les hommes veulent bien donner comme
valeur des changes
au début la monnaie c'était des
coquillages du grain du blé j'ai ici un
coquillage dans ma poche
oui alors c'est une coquille est mais
nous sommes dans un rêve pour échanger
les sommes données ces coquillages
ces grains de sel ces grains de blé mais
aussi ce bétail aujourd'hui dans nos
prisons les prisonniers s'échange encore
des choses en valeur de cigarettes
c'est pas qu'ils s'échangent des
cigarettes c'est qu'ils s'échangent des
objets en valeur de cigarettes
aujourd'hui bien entendu nous utilisons
les pièces et les billets comme ceci
cela existe depuis 2007 100 ans la
monnaie depuis ces 50 dernières années a
subi deux profondes mutations
la première c'est l'abandon de l'étalon
or
l'étalon or c'est cette part or que la
monnaie représente sur les avoirs
déposés en banque
l'étalon or a été abandonnée dans les
années 70 à cause de la financiarisation
de l'économie et notamment à cause de
l'inflation mais plus important encore
dans les années 80 l'arrivée de
l'ordinateur a complètement révolutionné
nos échanges et a eu un demande
d'accélération de ces échanges
fondamentale la manette traditionnelle
pièces et billets ne pouvait plus suivre
nous avons donc inventé la monnaie
électronique et les cartes bancaires
savez-vous qu aujourd'hui seulement 10%
de la masse monétaire persiste sous
forme de pièces et de billets le reste
n'est qu'électronique mais que la
monnaie soit réel ou électronique est là
quelque part effacer nos valeurs et nos
échanges humains l'argent en ivre
certains il faut se le jugement d'autres
en tant qu'entrepreneur je suis quelque
peu attristé par la perception de
nombreux français sur l'entrepreneur le
dirigeant d'entreprise on ne reproche
assez souvent de faire de l'argent je
peux vous dire qu'en tant
qu'entrepreneur l'ensemble de mes gains
et l'ensemble des gains que fut mon
entreprise sont réinvesties je ne peux
pas m'arrêter je ne peux pas ne pas
prendre des risques je gagnerai
certainement plus d'argent en
travaillant dans un grand groupe et tous
les entrepreneurs qui m'entourent oms au
virus alors il faudrait peut-être dans
cet argent réintroduire une valeur
morale une valeur humaine un peu lorsque
quand je fais un don à une association
j'aimerais être sûr que ce don hay
réellement au service de la cause que je
veux supporter alors il faudrait
réintroduire un traceur qui fait que
l'argent généré par l'entreprise
aïe uniquement à l'entrepreneuriat et
que l'argent que je donne aux
associations aïe uniquement au service
social des associations
et bien c'est tout à fait possible avec
la technologie et notamment grâce aux
cryptes monnaie et à la technologie
sous-jacente qui s'appelle la bloque
chaîne la bloque chaîne permet en plus
d'une valeur de la monnaie
d'ajouter une valeur humaine une valeur
des changes une chaîne de confiance et
de traçabilité lablaude chaîne c'est
comme si on n'y vrai on ouvrait ici ce
soir un livre sur lequel on écrirait
l'ensemble de nos maux de nos échanges
et se livre ce raid dupliqué dans des
centaines de millions d'autres livres
de par le monde de telle sorte que le
livre que nous écrivons ici ce soir nous
ne pourrons le modifier car il est déjà
réinscrits ailleurs c'est ça ce qu'on
appelle une chaîne de confiance
distribués c'est probablement l'avenir
des chaînes de scouts de confiance et
qui va donc permettre à la monnaie
d'inscrire des destinations et des
valeurs humaines qui ne sont aujourd'hui
plus présente
mais il y a peut-être d'autres moyens
aussi de répondre aux limitations
aujourd'hui du paiement et de la monnaie
que nous connaissons c'est plutôt lié à
l'utilisation de cette monnaie et je
dirais une utilisation avec précaution
une utilisation qu on pourrait presque
appeler bio c'est à dire une utilisation
raisonnée de la monnaie premier exemple
de cette utilisation raisonnée c'est
l'économie du partage aujourd'hui on
partage sa voiture on partage ces outils
on partage sa place de parking c'est
service de partage réintroduisent des
valeurs humaines le conducteur de la
voiture sera t'il fiable le passager
sera t'il aimable les sites de partages
introduisent des profils sociaux pour
répondre à ses attentes
chaque individu pourra dire s'il veut
être conduit avec quelqu'un qui parle ou
pas ou s'il souhaite être dans une
voiture de telle catégorie ou peints ou
passer par les chemins de traverse où
prendre que l'autoroute
les sites ont donc introduit en plus des
échanges des valeurs humaines qui
n'existait plus et pour ça on utilise
l'internet le mobile qui en plus de la
monnaie d échange les plateformes de
partage introduisent des profils sociaux
il y a aussi une autre application deux
utilisations résonnait de nos échanges
et de nos actes de paiement c'est
l'économie de l'usaj ou encore appelée
économie de l'abonnement je n'achète
plus mes films je n'achète plus mes
disques genou un usage sur une
plateforme de téléchargement l'économie
de l'usaj est au coeur de la société que
je dirige
tuellement qui s'occupent à la
transformation numérique des principaux
moyens d' usage et notamment du paiement
à l'acte répéter son possession du
produit
c'est très intéressant pour le
consommateur et pour l'économie en
général puisque c'est vraiment très
circulaire finalement on va utiliser le
produit que pour ce qu'on en a besoin et
on va ne payer que l' usage qu on leur a
fait à quoi sert le disque qui reste
dans notre étalage dans notre
bibliothèque
si on ne l'utilisent pas lyon ne
l'écoutent pas il vaut mieux payer juste
que son usage
cette société de l'usaj elle est en
train de se répandre partout elle répond
aussi à un besoin des fournisseurs de
biens et de services puisque ça permet
de pérenniser une offre et de rendre du
coup les revenus récurrents et
prédictible pour les fournisseurs de
services
c'est donc quelque chose qu'on regarde
de très près aujourd'hui il n'existe pas
une entreprise qui réfléchissent à
transformer son modèle économique pour
le transformer sous le modèle
d'abonnement
je prendrai quelques exemples avec
lesquels sociétés avec lesquelles nous
avons travaillé donc le train
l'abonnement outre un illimité mais
aussi l'abonnement bouteilles d'eau aux
couches-culottes au lait pour bébé aux
voitures puisqu'en fait aujourd'hui plus
de 50% des voitures sont maintenant
louer moins de 50% donc des conducteurs
achètent leur voiture
c'est une transformation fondamentale à
laquelle nous associons aussi notre
réflexion nous créer ce qu'on appelle
substation d'ab fab lab qui est en fait
une plateforme d échanges entre toutes
les entreprises pour réfléchir à un
changement des modèles de consommation
et des modèles de monétisation
alors finalement si le paiement est né
grâce à nos échanges
aujourd'hui nos échanges sont contraints
à cause de nos paiements l'acte de
paiement est vraiment une contrainte et
donc il faut bien entendu réfléchir à
comment changer nos échanges on rêverait
tous deux supprimer cette caisse là où
on attend et où vraiment on prend aucun
plaisir
personne ne prend un plaisir à payer on
voudrait fuir ce magasin quand on voit
une file d'attenté énorme et sur
laquelle on se dit que c'est vraiment
pas possible d'attendre aussi longtemps
alors bien sûr maintenant ont payé en
contact laisse ça prend un petit peu
plus vite mais c'est encore très
contraignant on rêve tous finalement de
quelque chose que nos grands mères que
les c'est ce qu'on appelait le contrat
l'épicerie on va les prix three on prend
tout ce qu'on veut et c'est fantastique
jusqu'à la fin du mois ou en fait notre
grand mère allait régler l'épicerie pour
bien entendu aujourd'hui avec les
technologies on pourra tout faire en
électronique
mais en fait ce ne sont pas des idées
très farfelues elle existait donc déjà
depuis longtemps
vous voyez cette chaîne de paiement du
coquillage jusqu'au mobile une
transformation incroyable qui s'est
opéré à une vitesse d'accélération
incroyable également on a eu récemment
un séminaire dans mon entreprise où on
réfléchissait à quelles pouvaient être
les paiements de demain et c'est assez
amusant une de mes collaboratrices
étrangères maîtrisons bien le français
mais quand même avec un petit peu de
naïveté me disait finalement jérôme je
voudrais payer avec mon corps
eh bien oui finalement c'est pas si bête
dans cette chaîne je suis l'acte de
paiement
la technologie me reconnais les caméras
vois mon visage mon iris mais mes doigts
pourquoi dois-je utiliser des
terminaisons en plastique pour payer
l'avenir du paiement c'est nous merci
[Applaudissements]